♪♪
TONY STARK:
It seems like a thousand
years ago...
I fought my way out
of that cave...
became Iron Man...
realized I loved you...
I know I said no more
surprises, but...
I was really hoping to
pull off one last one.
PEGGY CARTER:
The world has changed.
None of us can go back...
All we can
do is our best...
and sometimes the
best that we can do...
is to start over.
♪♪
THOR:
I saw all these people die.
STEVE ROGERS:
I keep telling everybody
they should move on...
Some do...
but not us.
NATASHA ROMANOFF:
Even if there's a...
small chance...
we owe this...
to everyone who's
not in this room
to try.
We will.
STEVE ROGERS:
Whatever it takes.
NEBULA:
Aaaaahhhh!
CLINT BARTON:
Whatever it takes.
NATASHA ROMANOFF:
TONY STARK:
Whatever it takes.
♪♪
I like this one.